es ist ja nicht alles nur schlecht ganz
ehrlich von außen betrachtet das ganze
latente Chaos in diesem Wahlkampf
das macht sie irgendwie sympathisch
bisher waren sie ja immer die Streber in
Europa Exportweltmeister schwarze Null alles
Tippi Tobi aber jetzt erinnern
sie mich immer mehr an Italien
jede Woche Skandal jeden Monat Chaos und das gibt
Ihnen so eine ganz neuen mediterrane Lässigkeit
aber ich weiß es ist auch schwierig diese
Veränderungen ja das ist da wird ja die
eigene Identität auch erschüttert und
man weiß nicht mehr als Landwehrmann ist
das geht auch uns Schweizer so jahrelang
war doch klar wir sind das langsamste Land
der Welt das war okay für uns da waren wir
auch ein bisschen stolz sie hatten schnelle
ICE-Züge wir halt langsamer Bergbahnen aber
mit all diesen Betrieb Signalstörungen und
Streiks bist du mittlerweile mit
der Schweizer Bergbahn schnell
und das nehme ich Ihnen echt übel dass sie uns da
jetzt unser Alleinstellungsmerkmal die Langsamkeit
streitig machen auch auf der Straße jeder weiß auf
deutschen Autobahnen kannst du so schnell fahren
wie du willst mit all diesen Baustellen und Staus
bist auf jedem Schweizer bergsträßlich schneller
gut in einem Punkt konnten wir uns die Langsamkeit
bewahren bis wir mal in der EU drin sein werden
sind alle anderen raus aber sonst was war das
in den letzten Jahren Stuttgart 21 Berliner
Flughafen natürlich Elbphilharmonie machen sie
das eigentlich extra dass das so langsam geht
was was denken sich diese
Baufirmen oh es wie beim Sex
kommen selbst wir langsamen
Schweizer nicht mehr mit und ja
ich weiß Elbphilharmonie ist schon lange
fertig warum die zuständigen Architekten